it is my privilege to be the first to
discover the winner of the award for the
best performance by an actor in a
supporting role and this is the
superlative list indeed Charles Bickford
in the farmer's daughter RKO radio
Thomas gomez in ride the pink horse
universal international Edmund Gwenn in
Miracle on 34th Street from Century Fox
Robert Ryan in crossfire RKO radio
Richard Widmark in kiss of death
Freddie a Century Fox the applause may
give you a clue when our winner Edmund
granite
twenty-fourth who congratulated by at
least twenty or thirty people while he's
making his way down in the over the
footlights and down to the state
and back
thank you and yeah now I know there's a
Santa Claus oh you may laugh ladies and
gentlemen not so easy to be certain you
know he's our most elusive little fella
turns up in all sorts of places under
all sorts of names and disguises first
time I ever met him he told me his name
was George Seaton and wonderfully George
Seaton had his revenge by bringing him
to life about a year and a half ago he
suddenly turned up at Culver City and
told me his name was metro-goldwyn-mayer
that was the day Metro agreed to loan me
the Fox to make the picture and now I
think it's time Santa Claus added a word
to his name I think you ought to call
himself Santa Claus incorporated Santa
Claus Inc Inc for then it will embrace
all you wonderful wonderful kind people
who have done in the honor of making me
stand here tonight thank you all of you
for making the evening of my life such a
happy one
you